Female Viagra say word woman's libido is
like the eighth wonder of the world it's
a mystery and scientists are trying to
crack the code they are submitting to
the FDA right now for the third time a
woman's viagra which actually instead of
targeting down here targets up here but
the question remains will women actually
take that drug are they interested in it
is there a need we came to suburbia
California where there's a Lululemon on
one corner and a Sephora on the other to
find out ready
what are your thoughts on a female
viagra would you take something like no
I probably would why is that I think I
really mean you don't need it I don't
even know to say I don't know why we
would need that is there a double
standard when it comes to sexual health
I think it's just we're more cautious I
feel like I don't think society views
women as sexual beings as much as they
view men as sexual beings and our
sexuality isn't really talked about as
much as male sexuality they're calling
it a disorder what's this let's see
sexual dysfunction
ridiculous it's I think being in a
long-term relationship with some men
would lead anyone to lose their libido
they lose interest in general because of
kids and everything else that they are
exhausted look that's what I'm hearing a
lot of my friends so I don't know if
they would take it cuz they're like they
can't be bothered yeah would you take
something like that I think I would
think as a middle-aged mother of two
young children I think that would be
very helpful in my age I yes I would
definitely because I'm 50 and I think
that it's important that women's
sexuality is as enjoyable as men maybe
we need an expert opinion
Steven Stahl is a doctor who thinks the
FDA should approve the drug the drug is
called flibanserin and it works on the
brain he explained the drug up's
chemicals like dopamine to increase
desire what do you think about the
breadth of medical knowledge of female
libido and sexuality I think that it's
it's basically a stigmatized thing which
has not talked about and therefore
mysterious and often misunderstood and
so again when a new drug comes out that
works
it is very creates a dialogue and
creates publicity it makes people
rethink things and also think along the
spectrum okay but what about meditation
therapy a babysitter date night or your
partner picking up some slack wouldn't
that increase desire I say what ever
works use it and I would much rather
have people use yoga than a pill thanks
dr. Steve but I still think I need some
more seasoned advice that's why I headed
to a Senior Center
what are your thoughts on something like
a female viagra take something like no
good one well because I'm too old I mean
I'm 95 oh no I could pick it and I don't
want it no you're all good you know the
Food and Drug Administration is
considering approving a female viagra oh
that's all other nonsense well you have
to start from up here to get everything
else going I don't see the point I mean
what why look for artificially for sex
teach men how to make love I think that
if you're that type of a woman and we
wanted more sex and you you didn't get
your suffer I think right not take a
pill wouldn't the Jenny get tired of ham
and eggs if you ate that every morning a
man came in a little fist bump
oh now and then it'd be nice to have a
waffle
it is opening weekend for fifty Shades
of Grey the book that has sold over a
hundred million copies and has audience
members on their knee